[Music]
hey
last month i went dancing at this cute
spot in florida
where my roommate's girl made like five
g's a night
[Music]
we just met yesterday and you're already
trying to take whole trips together
be ready by two hi
you wanna hear a story about how me and
this [ __ ] fell out it's kinda long
but it's felicia's face
you wanna go somewhere with me face
dear heavenly father we are asking you a
special prayer today
we asking you to send us [ __ ]
[ __ ] with culture steamed us [ __ ]
with good credit
what brings y'all here we making money
money
cities money cities from here on out
watch every move this [ __ ] make
[Applause]
in my face word
y'all want a trap okay wait hold up
do not trip i got you girls
a real nice spot this is messy
you are messy your brain is broke
is this what you came here for do it
look like i came for this money you made
i'm so proud of you
i don't [ __ ] with you no more i didn't
do nothing wrong
i came to dance no no no we're done with
that
why you on my twitter why are you on my
facebook why are you on my tumblr why
are you dming me
sis why are you tagging me in photos you
don't even [ __ ] with me let me know let
me know
[Music]
yes
you